in this video we'll see how to compute
the gradient of the last function with
respect to the parameters of the log
unary factors in a conditional random
field so we are deriving the stochastic
gradient descent training algorithm for
conditional random field a linear chain
conditional random field we've seen the
last function before and now we're going
to start looking at how to compute the
gradients with respect to the different
parameters of the log linear conditional
random field before we've defined the
loss as the negative log of the
probability of the true label sequence
given the input sequence so let's look
at the gradient alright so we'll focus
now on the gradient with respect to the
unary log factors that is au of YK prime
where YK prime can be any class label so
it's not necessarily the observed class
labels or any class label so the partial
derivative of the negative log of the
property of the given sequence Y given
some input sequence X with respect to
the unary factor for some arbitrary
label Y Prime at position K is going to
be actually quite similar to the
gradient of the pre activation at the
output layer of a neural network it's
going to be minus the the identity
function of whether Y K so the K F label
and Y here is equal to Y prime K which
is the label for which we are
considering the parameters of the unary
factors minus the probability according
to our model of actually observing for
the K label the actual value y prime K
for the given input so again we have
this formula which is essentially minus
what we would like to see which is that
well oh sorry what we actually observe
which is a label of YK minus y
we currently predict so we have
essentially a term here which is only
one when we're considering the Union
factor for the correct answer minus the
probability distribution of the current
value for the current value of the
parameters of the conditional random
field for the kieth label because that's
actually quite similar to the neural
network reactivation value at the output
layer for classification that we seen
before so if we consider the specific
case of a conditional random field where
we have for a given context of ages one
three different neural networks one that
computes some pre activation based on
the current position another one based
on the input on the left and then the
one based on the input on the look right
so we consider the gradient with respect
to all of these pre activation function
at the output layer of these three
neural networks that would give us the
following gradients with the minus the
one hot vector with a one at the real
value of the label at position K minus
the vector of marginal probabilities for
what the label might be according to the
current conditional random field for
position okay so that's for the neural
network that looks at the input at the
current position K and if we for the one
that's looking on the left well the
green is gonna be 0 if K is equal to 1
so if it's not greater than 1 and that's
because and for K equals 1 there is no
neural net trying to predict from X 0
since X 0 doesn't exist and similarly we
have also an indicator function for the
one that looks to the right so that the
green it is 0 if K is equal to capital K
so now let's look at the derivation for
this formula for how so let's try to see
why this is true
alright so we're looking at the partial
derivative of the negative log
probability of some vector of labels Y
given some input X with respect to the
log factor the unary lock factor and its
value for some given label y prime K so
ok it means we're looking at the
position K in the sequence and write
prime K would be some value between 1
and capital C so here the only thing
I've done is just write what is minus
the log of P of Y given X for a log
linear sorry for a linear chain CRF so
remember we have the log of the
exponential of these terms so we just
have these terms once we apply the log
minus the log of set because before we
had divided divided by the partition
function so the log of that would be
minus the log of the partition function
now the gradients of this sorry the
partial derivative of this whole
expression with respect to that term is
going to be 1 if the care label is
actually Y prime K otherwise that
particular expression is not gonna be
it's not gonna appear here okay so the
gradient for any other position then K
of these terms here is zero the green
the derivative with respect to that of
that sorry with respect to this is also
zero so it's only the case for the same
K which is important and if YK is equal
to prime prime K then we'll have exactly
the same term so the relief of that is
going to be 1 otherwise it going to be 0
and then minus the derivative of the log
partition function so we're just by the
narrative to this minus iterative to of
that so let's do that specific term the
derivative of the log partition function
so derivative of the log is just 1 over
that 1 over Z times the derivative of
whatever we're taking the logarithm in
logarithm of now here I'm just writing
the expression for the partition
function so because I've used the symbol
Y
prime K I'll use instead of Y prime
prime for reference to the sequence of
always over which I'm taking this sum
here the nest at some now I can push the
so the derivative of the sum is the sum
of the derivative so I can push that
there the inside here so right here
that's what I've done right here and now
the narrative of the exponentiated sum
of factors a lot of factors well if here
a uy prime K does not appear that it's
zero and its it won't have it won't
appear if Y prime K is not equal in the
sequence Y prime is not equal to Y prime
prime K also in the sequence Y prime
prime K if at the position K its value
is not the value of y prime K then the
then the third F of that is going to be
zero it's going in because it's going to
be constant with respect to that
variable however if it does appear then
the derivative of the exponential is the
exponential itself so it's gonna be that
term and times the derivative of the
argument well it's just gonna be one
much like it was one right here
so essentially what we'll get is the
indicator function of whether y prime K
is equal to Y prime prime K times the
exponential of the sum of all log
factors now let's notice that here
that's the numerator of the probability
the conditional probability in the
conditional random field and that's the
partition function so I can just remove
it here and just divide by it here and
then what do I get
well I get that this whole term here is
just the probability of observing as the
sequence of labels Y prime prime 1
followed by Y prime 2 up to Y prime
prime capital K
and then this term here is here and now
if I take the sum over all possible
sequences of and I only consider the
terms where in all these sequences I
don't consider the sequences such that Y
prime prime K is equal to Y prime K then
I'm just summing the probability of all
sequences which satisfy this condition
so all sequences such that the key
element in the sequence is ripe ranking
and so the sum of all of these joint
probability is just a marginal
probability that Y prime K is DK table
in the sequence so I do obtain that this
term here is P of Y prime K given x
mm-hmm and so I do have that the
gradients the parts of the other would
respect to the log unary factor is the
indicator function minus the probability
under the model so that's great I know
we now have the gradient of the and the
partial derivative with respect to the
log unary factor but we don't have it
with respect to the parameters in the
log in every factor fortunately we've
seen that the back propagation allows us
to very efficiently apply the chain rule
and back propagate the gradients to all
the parameters so essentially from the
parameters of the log linear factors
that gives me essentially the the
partial derivative with respect to the
pre activation values at the output
layer of the neural Nets inside this
area and then I can just take those
gradients those partial derivatives and
back propagate them towards all the
parameters of the model now notice that
because it's the same neural network at
each position in the conditional random
field I need to accumulate all the
gradients for every position and the
sequence
so all these grains need to be
accumulated into the my computation of
the parameter gradients so let's look at
the specific case of linear linear chain
conditional random field so the case
where the
factors on linear so this would be the
neural network from the center the
computation that looks at the aligned
input so being linear transformation
plus bias then we have the computation
that looks at sorry that's a mistake
that should be oh no sir yeah so that's
one way of writing it I could have
written it K minus 1 here and K minus 1
here I could've written K plus 1 here k
plus 1 here but let's just assume now
that we have this log linear model where
the unary log factors are just linear
function of the context window so in
this case the gradient with respect to
the bias and also I just want to say
that notice I didn't put a bias here or
here and that's because I would just be
redundant since I mean just a single
bias is sufficient so the gradient
respect of the bias would be the
gradient with respect to the pre
activation function for the center of
the window but summed over all positions
so that's the queen of the pre
activation function at all position K so
for all inputs XK all position K
actually and we've seen before that the
gradient was essentially this the one
hot dr. minus the vector of marginal
probabilities for position gain so I'm
just summing over all positions game and
now if I want the gradient with respect
to the weights that connects the input
that's at the current position K or
that's to the left or to the right well
I get something that's essentially very
similar it's again the 100m is the
vector marginal probabilities but for
this part of the this parameter matrix a
multiplied by the transpose of the
vector aligned with the current position
K this one I multiplied
the vector to the left the transpose of
the vector to the left he transposed to
the of the vector to the right